there is nothing subtle about joseph
gordon-levitt or jamie foxx in their new
netflix movie which has them channeling
some very dark superhero skills
how would you describe this picture i
have jowls like a bulldog
and the spirit to match
so that's your power the power that my
character has is he's bulletproof
they had this powerful air gun and they
shot my face with this blast of air
and then animated the gunshot over that
but the air is really hitting me
then the most interesting thing is like
the cgi
is is minimum on the film all my stuff
done on my character it's all real
there's no cgi
yeah that's the reaction people are like
what listen to my voice
am i lying just to frame the movie
it's about a drug on the street where
you take it and you get
five minutes of super power jamie joseph
and rodrigo's new netflix thriller
project power debuts tomorrow
it's full of action and unbelievable
stunts like megan fox's guy
rapper machine gun kelly on fire
but if you ask jamie the real star of
the movie is 29 year old dominique
fishbach
she plays a high school student teaming
up with jamie to find the source
of the power drugs you're watching the
emergence of an actress that i tell you
one day will be standing up
and saying i want to thank all of the
members i'm telling you
i thought we would like batman no batman
and robin that's a movie this is real
life we doing this
these two bonded long before they were
on set it actually happened at
dominique's audition
right after she lost her wallet oh jimmy
you need cash cause cause i got cash
pulled out 100 bills gives it to me and
by the end when we wrap the movie i
signed a hundred dollar bill i put it in
the frame with a picture of me and jamie
and i gave it to him and he said don't
give me that because i'm gonna spend it